et notre invité ce matin c'est le
général d'armée Benoît Puga bonjour
général merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous êtes en sciences
chef d'état-major particulier de la
présidence ancien Grand Chancelier de la
Légion d'honneur et général évidemment
difficile avec un ancien militaire de
votre grade de ne pas commencer en
évoquant ce qui se passe actuellement en
Ukraine on est 15 mois après le début de
l'invasion russe qu'est-ce que vous
retenez de ce conflit au bout de 15 mois
je retiens trois trois éléments d'abord
le premier je voudrais rappeler que je
ne suis plus aux affaires et donc je
n'ai pas accès à l'information et je me
garderai bien de porter des jugements
donc sur la situation actuelle mais
premier élément c'est que encore
aujourd'hui au 21ème siècle nous pouvons
rencontrer des situations
insurrectionnelles des situations de
guerre particulièrement dangereuse et
terribles qui provoque des morts et des
destructions et en conséquence il est
utile à la fois d'anticiper de se
préparer de s'unir de s'allier pour
pouvoir faire face à ce type de
situation deuxièmement d'un point de vue
plus militaire on peut constater que
face à une agression il est important de
pouvoir résister pour résister c'est
d'abord une question de volonté de
volonté humaine de cohésion c'est à dire
que le partage des valeurs le partage de
d'un sentiment d'unité de avec des
camarades avec la population avec les
habitants sa famille et particulièrement
important à la limite plus importante
que le matériel et l'équipement c'est la
volonté de se battre la volonté de ses
défendre et à cet égard évidemment la
population
ukrainienne en fait une très belle
démonstration enfin c'est que il est
également très important de d'envisager
l'avenir à chaque fois qu'on s'engage
dans une opération c'est toujours
d'avoir en tête de pensée du coup et
d'après qu'est-ce qui va se passer
quelle est la situation nous allons
fêter aujourd'hui enfin c'est cette
année où il est le 80e anniversaire du
CNR vous savez le Conseil voilà de la
résistance qui a défini justement 43 ce
qui est quand même incroyable envisager
la suite y compris les affaires comme la
sécurité sociale voilà est-ce que de ce
que vous voyez on vous le rappelez vous
n'êtes plus aux affaires mais est-ce
qu'on peut parler dans les Semans
aujourd'hui dans cette guerre est ce que
selon vous la Russie a encore les moyens
de prendre des initiatives et de mener
des offensives je pense que oui d'une
certaine manière la Russie a toujours la
possibilité de relancer des enfants si
d'ailleurs elle le dit
la possibilité ne pas ne veut pas dire
en avoir la capacité et être notamment
en mesure de réussir
l'échec de l'offensive de des Russes au
début de cette affaire en février de
l'année dernière à démontré que ça ne
suffit pas de vouloir encore faut-il
avoir la capacité et encore faut-il
avoir l'organisation qui le qui le
permettent mais je crains que
ce qu'il en tout cas ils n'en font pas
la démonstration et encore une fois j'ai
pas toutes les informations ce que je
constate malheureusement c'est un peu
comme pendant le premier conflit mondial
en France d'être malheureusement un
moment vous avez un équilibre comme
souvent sur des théâtres de guerre et
cette équilibre est très meurtrier mais
aucun des deux parties n'a suffisamment
l'ascendant pour prendre le pas sur
l'adversaire et pouvoir progresser et
malheureusement ce type de situation
d'équilibre fait que vous pouvez avoir
des succès ponctuels mais pas suffisant
pour entraîner une mécanique qui
conduise à la paix ça vous a surpris ou
que la Russie n'est pas réussie à
prendre l'ascendant sur l'Ukraine et
finalement sont encore enlisée dans
cette gare 15 mois après non été anciens
directeur du enseignement militaire le
je n'ai pas été surpris par la faiblesse
de la capacité militaire russe même s'il
faut pas se tromper elle possède de
réels capacités en revanche qui m'a
surpris c'est qu'à partir du moment où
les autorités russes ont décidé de
malheureusement de franchir cette
frontière et d'attaquer l'Ukraine ça
n'est pas été mieux organisé comment
vous l'expliquez est-ce que vous
Vladimir Poutine assurété son armée
est-ce qu'elle a eu de mauvaises
informations est-ce qu'il a une mauvaise
organisation très honnêtement je sais
pas mauvaise organisation on a pu le
voir on a pu le constater mauvaise
peut-être mauvais
mauvaise perception de la capacité
opérationnelle de ces unités nous avons
vu ces unités à la fois rues
ukrainiennes nous les suivons de plus de
nombreuses années ils étaient à nos
côtés lorsque il y a eu des opérations
de l'ONU par exemple pour next
Yougoslavie et donc on connaissait les
aptitudes mais c'est vrai qu'on a été
surpris de ce niveau de faiblesse est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment aujourd'hui
que Vladimir Poutine Poutine contrôle
encore la situation
c'est difficile à dire honnêtement je
n'ai pas de d'information je dirais
simplement en tout cas actuellement
c'est qu'on a une stabilisation
malheureusement du front et ce qui veut
dire que les souffrances et les
difficultés vont poursuivre pour le
peuple crinien c'est une guerre qui peut
durer encore longtemps mon sentiment est
que oui malheureusement
sur un mot sur le rôle de Wagner ce
groupe de mercenaire russe notamment
dans la ville de darkmouth est-ce que
Vladimir Poutine peut gagner cette
guerre sans Wagner on a entendu Wagner
très critique envers Vladimir Poutine
cette semaine très franchement je n'aime
pas parler de Wagner je pense que c'est
une milice elle vient d'être condamnée
par l'Union européenne qui estime que
maintenant c'est une organisation
terroriste et je trouve qu'on fait trop
français qui ont voté en 197 semaines et
je pense que c'est quand même
je veux pas faire de publicité pour
cette pour cette organisation après
c'est le problème de Poutine de son
arrangé
on va parler de l'Afrique dans quelques
instants puisque évidemment Wagner est
aussi présent en Afrique mais du côté
ukrainien est-ce que vous quel rôle a
joué le renseignement dans la Résistance
ukrainienne selon vous
comme partout c'est un rôle fondamental
mais ce n'est pas ce qui explique la
résistance de la population
ukrainienne ce qui est certain c'est que
comme tout le monde comme vous comme moi
comme tous nos compatriotes nous avons
besoin d'informations et de
renseignements pour vivre tous les jours
lorsque vous êtes dans une situation de
guerre évidemment ce besoin il est
encore plus affirmé plus important parce
que vous avez un risque et un risque
vital que vous affrontez en conséquence
effectivement mieux vous êtes renseigné
plus vite vous pouvez vous organiser
vous pouvez anticiper et éviter
justement des pertes évitez les coups
durs pour prendre l'exemple en ce moment
de la possibilité d'en offensive puisque
les conditions météo et donc les le
terrain se prêtera plus facilement à des
opérations évidemment plus vous avez de
renseignements qui vous permettent
d'affiner les objectifs à neutraliser à
détruire qui vous
la victoire d'emporter des gains
substantiels sur le terrain bien sûr
mieux c'est si en plus vous avez des
informations sur les capacités de
l'adversaire la façon dont lui peut
venir vous nuire évidemment c'est
formidable et donc c'est un travail
permanent quotidien passionnant mais
très difficile à un mot sur l'offensive
la contre-offensive
dont on ne sait pas très bien quand elle
va avoir lieu vous le dit merci dit que
finalement l'armée
ukrainienne n'est peut-être pas prête
tout de suite est-ce que il y a une
guerre d'usure psychologique aussi quand
vous préparez une contre-offensive bien
entendu le problème plus une guerre dure
plus effectivement vous avez une
pression sur la population sur les
combattants c'est l'impatience c'est la
fatigue c'est le fait de pas savoir
lorsque la crise se terminera c'est ce
que malheureusement
nos compatriotes nos anciens ont vécu
pendant Première Guerre mondiale qui a
quand même duré plus de 4 ans et donc
vous avez une usure une fatigue tout le
monde sait ce qui s'est passé en 1917 si
vous voulez en France là c'est la même
chose toute cause une cause peut
produire les mêmes effets et là c'est le
cas donc vous avez effectivement une
facture une fatigue et une usure qui est
magnifique qui est manifeste et donc
c'est au commandement c'est aux aut côté
de faire en sorte de trouver les voies
et moyens pour permettre aux gens de se
ressourcer de de surposer en même temps
de se préparer c'est-à-dire de maintenir
le niveau opérationnel continuez à fuer
les gens salavrés la vraie difficulté
de laisser les soldats russes sur le
petit vive exactement et c'est plus vous
pouvez semer l'incertitude chez
l'adversaire et au contraire permettre
donner de la confiance chez vous mais
on va parler juste à un dernier mot
là-dessus puisque vous étiez jusqu'à
janvier dernier grand chancelier de la
Légion d'honneur il y a un débat qui
resurgit régulièrement c'est est-ce
qu'il faut retirer le grand la grande
croix de la Légion d'honneur à Vladimir
Poutine alors d'abord c'est une décision
qui relève du grand maître du président
de la République et ensuite comme vous
le savez depuis Napoléon Bonaparte qui a
le premier
décoré donc des autorités
gouvernementales car on est encore moins
la personne
que le pays c'est-à-dire lorsqu'il y a
une décoration
qui est protocolaire d'un chef d'État le
président de la République Grand Maître
de l'Ordre en fait montre la nature la
qualité de la relation stratégique entre
deux pays c'est pour ça que autrefois le
président Chirac avait décoré Bachar
el-Assad et c'est pour ça que le
président Poutine a été décoré donc
c'est moins la personne une Twitter
personnelle qui est qui est décorée que
la relation la qualité de la relation
entre la France et la Russie moi j'ai
tendance à dire il y aura un demain la
France la Russie fait partie de l'Europe
là aussi elle fait partie de notre
histoire et l'histoire a été jalonnée
des on a aimé et on a détesté la Russie
on a eu des alliances tout le monde
connaît l'alliance franco-rus etc donc
il y aura un lendemain donc c'est une
décision
oui je pense alors à quelle échéance je
laisse ça politique c'est pas à moi d'en
juger mais c'est une réalité donc pour
revenir à votre question oui c'est une
question qui se pose qui se pose
aujourd'hui est-ce que elle est
d'actualité je suis pas sûr que ça
contribue c'est quelque chose qui se
traitera par la suite
ça pourrait être un président de la
République dans juger je constate que
c'est pas la priorité du moment priorité
du moment c'est effectivement de
soulager l'armée ukrainienne et le
peuple ukrainien on va parler de
l'Afrique qui est un terrain que vous
connaissez très bien vous êtes
intervenus sur de nombreux terrains dont
nombreuses circonstances notamment aux
haïr aujourd'hui République démocratique
du Congo dans le cadre de l'opération
colvésie il y a 45 ans il y aura
d'ailleurs vous allez intervenir
d'ailleurs un au Sénat à ce sujet le 22
mai dans le cadre d'un coloc organisé
par la Fondation Giscard d'Estaing
qu'est-ce que vous pensez aujourd'hui de
la présence française en Afrique est-ce
qu'on va vers la fin de cette présence
française non je ne pense pas je pense
que comme toujours dans les relations
entre deux pays maintenant c'est plus
qu'un pays c'est continent c'est un
continent d'avenir les autorités
politiques françaises l'ont dit à
plusieurs reprises c'est un continent
jeune c'est incontinent qui possède des
richesses notamment dans son sous-sol
particulièrement énorme qui a une
capacité humaine qui va se déplacer
enfin développer et donc il est très
important de d'avoir une relation
étroite parce que ils sont à nos pieds
nous sommes le bassin méditerranéen
voilà c'est de l'autre côté nous avons
l'Afrique et nous avons des liens très
étroits très présents avec les peuples
africains maintenant comme toujours ceci
évolue et on oublie souvent que la
relation entre deux pays elle est faite
c'est aussi la population c'est pas
seulement les autorités et donc il
s'agit de créer des liens qui permettent
dans tous les domaines que ce soit
culturel politique économique sociale de
de créer des des alliances et donc pour
moi la frite non on change peut-être de
paradigme on change de maux de tête ça
avait déjà été engagé à parler de la
disparition de la France Afrique j'y
crois je pense que là on change de
paradigme c'est-à-dire non je pense
qu'il y a une situation qui a qui a
évolué vous avez un pays qui ne souhaite
plus là la présence de la France il est
souverain et donc on quitte c'est tout à
fait naturel ça veut pas dire pour
autant que ce qu'on a fait avant il y a
quelques semaines de départ en français
pour vous c'est pas un échec mais tout
dépend d'abord c'est pas un échec par
rapport à qui ou par rapport à quoi pour
le peuple burkinabé c'est un choix
souverain il est il est chez lui il est
dans son pays pour nous on peut le
regretter mais il y aura un jour après
et je pense que les Burkinabés sont des
gens extraordinaires on a eu toujours
des liens fantastiques avec eux beaucoup
d'élite et beaucoup de personnels au
Burkina Faso ont été formés en France et
on reviendra la manière ou d'une autre
on se rappelait maintenant c'est au
peuple de le définir et puis nous on ira
peut-être c'est dans un autre pays moi
je pense que ça bouge on est on a été
dans ces pays alors demande on est on
n'a pas forcé la porte on a été dans ces
pays parce qu'ils le souhaitaient
subitement ils estiment que maintenant
les conditions ont changé ils veulent
changer vont changent pareil au malien
le président de la République Emmanuel
Macron a acté la fin de l'opération
barkhane il y a quelques mois tel
qu'elle avait été lancée vous étiez
d'ailleurs un au cœur des décisions
puisque vous étiez chef d'état-major
particulier de François Hollande quel
regard vous portez aujourd'hui sur cette
opération d'arcade je pense qu'il y a
deux volets d'abord cette opération a
été exemplaire dans la mesure c'est une
opération qui s'est déroulée face à une
réelle menace de djihadiste qui de
terroristes qui faisait subir à la
population des choses épouvantables et
qui est menacé de s'emparer du pays on
peut dire aujourd'hui celui que la
menace était plus ou moins forte elle
était réelle deuxièmement des autorités
du pays et les pays voisins les pays
africains ont demandé à la France ont
demandé à la communauté internationale
d'intervenir et justement toute une
démarche avait été faite c'est pour ça
cette opération a très bien marché parce
que il y a eu une unité de la communauté
internationale de tous les pays avec
l'ONU et surtout de tous les pays
africains pour effectivement faire
quelque chose et donc la mission réussie
c'est-à-dire dans un premier temps on a
neutralisé la menace je dis pas qu'on
l'a éradiqué on a neutralisé la menace
parce qu'après il faut traiter si vous
voulez les racines de la difficulté
ensuite ils sont encore là mais qui sont
encore là puisqu'on le voit vous avez
toujours des trafics vous avez toujours
malheureusement des terroristes vous
avez toujours le l'utilisation des
trafics humains si vous voyez qui sont
quand même assez dramatique mais le
résultat il a été là c'est-à-dire que
vous avez eu un processus politique qui
a conduit à l'élection d'un parlement a
conduit à l'élection d'un président de
la République qui a conduit à des
accords y compris avec les Touaregs et
ensuite c'est appliqué après le pays
estime que maintenant sa politique doit
changer il est souverain quand il faut
savoir partir le président de la
République a décidé que c'était le
moment de partir mais tout ce qui a été
fait auparavant et quand même un acquis
c'est-à-dire on a quand même réduit une
menace qui menaçait précisément de
gangrener l'ensemble de la population
malheureusement on le voit un petit peu
ce qui se passe au Burkina Faso et donc
on peut comprendre l'inquiétude et je
pense qu'il y a toujours une inquiétude
de déstabilisation de certains pays mais
c'est assez pays de prendre en compte
cette menace et éventuellement de
d'appeler la communauté internationale
d'autres pays à venir les aider et c'est
là qu'on en revient à Wagner
russe est-ce qu'il contribue à cette
déstabilisation est-ce qu'ils sont en
train de profiter de l'affaiblissement
des forces françaises sur place ils en
profitent bien évidemment parce que
derrière il vous avez des affaires
d'argent sordides et puis deuxième
encore une fois c'est une organisation
terroriste dans quel s'infiltre partout
et on les voit mais mais je pense que là
aussi les autorités locales se rendront
compte de ce que vaut ce type de milice
est-ce qu'ils font maintenir encore
aujourd'hui des soldats français en
Afrique il faut maintenir la présence
militaire française sur ce continent moi
je pense oui à partir du moment où les
autorités locales le souhaitent et vous
avez beaucoup de pays africains avec
lesquels nous avons des relations
particulièrement étroites qui passent
par justement de la formation plus nous
pourrons aider les pays africains à
régler leurs problèmes à se former sur
leur pays à les aider à mettre en place
comme ils le souhaitent d'ailleurs des
des formations plus nous pourrons
concourir à la stabilité de l'Afrique et
moi j'y croyais permettre son
développement et ça vous paraît possible
après un sentiment anti-français qui est
en train de se développer en Afrique
mais il est bon comme toujours vous avez
des rapports de force et ce qui profite
à l'un profite à l'autre donc vous avez
évidemment ce qui est nuisible pour nous
vous avez des gens qui essayent d'en
profiter faut pas être naïf et il faut
bien voir derrière le sentiment que
certains prêtent anti-français vous avez
des gens qui veulent prendre la place de
la France après encore une fois c'est au
pays africain souverain de se déterminer
on va parler de la loi de programmation
militaire qui arrive au Parlement qui
est actuellement en commission à
l'Assemblée nationale 413 milliards
d'euros sur 7 ans après l'augmentation
du précédent budget le budget de la
défense aura donc doublé sur les chaînes
d'une décennie est-ce que le
gouvernement qui parle d'un effort
historique est-ce que compte tenu de
l'état de l'armée française l'effort est
suffisant
je dirais qu'il y a de voler dans votre
question d'abord c'est un effort
significatif qui a reconnu par tout le
monde et qui correspond aux engagements
qu'a pris le président de la République
lorsqu'il a été élu donc en 2017
deuxièmement est-ce que c'est suffisant
en partie oui toujours une question
d'équilibre ce que vous donnez à
quelqu'un vous le prenez à de l'autre
malheureusement nous connaissons la
situation des finances publiques et donc
pour le président de la République je
suis pas encore une fois dans le secret
des dieux puisque je ne suis plus aux
affaires mais c'est toujours une
question d'équilibre ce que vous donnez
à l'éducation nationale vous pouvez pas
le donner aux armées vous pouvez pas le
donner à la culture donc faut trouver un
bon équilibre cet équilibre il est
calculé en fonction de la menace et des
risques auxquels nous sommes confrontés
les Français ne compatriotes sont
conscients qu'en ce moment on a la foi
une menace terroriste qui est qui est
réel même si on a pu l'endiguer d'une
certaine manière mais et vous avez aussi
une menace à nos pas très loin de nos
frontières qui montrent que
malheureusement le cas de conflits est
possible donc il faut pas désarmer si je
puis dire à la fois intellectuellement
et physiquement ensuite il faut une
cohérence d'ensemble et c'est cette
cohérence qui est importante derrière le
volume d'argent ce qui est important
c'est la répartition c'est le volume et
notamment non seulement les grands
programmes comme le porte-avion mais moi
j'insiste toujours sur ce qu'on appelle
les programmes de cohérence
opérationnelle c'est à dire en fait
l'huile qui fait que l'ensemble
fonctionne depuis le renseignement
jusqu'à la cybersécurité qui est très à
la mode justement sur quoi il faut être
les priorités selon vous sur la
formation sur le renseignement sur la
cybersécurité à la fois sur les domaines
que vous venez de citer mais aussi
l'infrastructure mais aussi des domaines
ou quelquefois on fait des économies
vous voulez vous voulez faire des
économies vous réparez pas la petite
fuite qui est sur votre toit vous
attendez un an deux ans trois ans au
bout de quatre ans
voilà tout le toit qu'il faut changer
donc c'est une qui est là encore une
question d'équilibre et je le répète je
suis pas haut aux affaires mais je crois
que c'est cet équilibre entre les grands
programmes et les petits programmes qui
est très importants de ce que vous savez
de l'état de l'armée française que vous
connaissez évidemment très bien et ce
qu'aujourd'hui l'armée française serait
en mesure de tenir un conflit de haute
intensité oui
définitivement oui nous avons une
qualité de personnel une qualité de
recrutement une qualité de
l'entraînement bien sûr qu'on peut faire
mieux et on peut jamais s'arrêter on
tend on dirait les mathématiciens à
symptotiquement vers donc le 100% mais
on obtient jamais mais nous avons des
cadres de qualité qui l'ont montré sur
le terrain nous avons les gens qui se
dévouent des gens qui sont capables de
donner leur vie pour justement les
missions et pour les personnes qu'ils
défendent et ça c'est un véritable
espoir moi je suis très très optimiste
maintenant comme toujours c'est un
travail de tous les instants et
notamment du commandement vous parliez
du recrutement est-ce que aujourd'hui
l'armée française est encore en capacité
de recruter est-ce qu'il y a pas des
problèmes de recrutement il y a plus des
problèmes de fidélisation que de
recrutement enfin mais là encore je suis
pas au courant des derniers chiffres
mais d'abord en ce moment on est un peu
en période de pleine emploi et c'est
toujours la même chose quand vous êtes
en période de Pôle emploi il faut être
attractif il faut trouver
ensuite c'est la fidélisation tout le
monde dans tous les métiers on constate
aujourd'hui que les jeunes font un peu
du zapping et qu'on a du mal à maintenir
des gens conformes dans la spécialité et
on n'arrive pas à savoir pourquoi ils
changent je pense qu'il y a une
évolution de la mentalité des jeunes moi
j'enseigne donc on voit bien que les
jeunes sont plus intéressés à rentrer
dans une carrière pour faire toute leur
vie dans cette carrière
où les jeunes dans l'armée en se disant
ça va être comme ça puis une fois qu'ils
sont dedans ils se rendent compte que
c'est très dur oui mais au-delà de la je
pense que beaucoup rentrent dans les
armées parce que on recrute des jeunes
qui ont l'aptitude mais pas forcément la
formation et on les forme et après dans
le contrat au cours des 3 ans on leur
donne réellement une formation et cette
formation elle est elle est
commercialisable si je puis dire dans
dans le civil les gens sont contents ils
savent conduire ils ont des gens qui
arrivent à l'heure des gens qui sont
disponibles des gens qui se dévouent ça
c'est c'est très précieux et tout le
monde le recherche quel que soit les
métiers vous avez le sentiment que les
Français aujourd'hui sont encore
attachés à leur armée je pense que oui
je pense que en particulier depuis les
les attentats mais pas seulement je
pense que les les Français ont constaté
moi je vois tous sur ma carrière de 50
ans je suis rentré dans les armées
c'était les comités de soldats nous
sommes je le quitte bon on a le conflit
en Ukraine ce qui prouve qu'il y a
toujours des situations de crise mais je
je pense que les Français sont attachés
à leur armée parce qu'ils en ont vu les
effets sur le terrain à la fois à
l'étranger ou quand même y compris dans
l'exemple du Mali le travail a été fait
une solution politique a été mise en
place grâce au travail et au sacrifice
des soldats qui ont été conduits au Mali
c'est une réalité même si aujourd'hui
nous quittons le Mali ça n'empêche que
pendant quelques années on a contribué
au développement de du Mali sur le plan
intérieur les les attentats ont permis
aux Français de de comprendre que les
forces de sécurité de police de
gendarmerie ainsi que les forces
militaires contribuaient à la protection
et à la défense du territoire à la
protection des Français c'est la mission
première des forces armées d'ailleurs
une dernière question peut-être
un petit général parmi toutes vos
fonctions toutes vos missions dans les
plus hautes sphères militaires
politiques laquelle vous a le plus plus
le plus marqué
toutes mais je vous avoue très
honnêtement que je recommencerai bien à
25 ans quand j'étais chef de section
sautant un colvésie il y a 45 ans
j'aurais recommencé genre je
recommencerai demain et pour il faudrait
que je sois un petit peu plus comment
dire raffiné sur le plan physique mais
j'aurais beaucoup mais j'ai eu de la
chance de tous les niveaux vous avez de
des responsabilités qui ont été
passionnantes et avoir été lieutenant à
Kolwezi avoir entendu le président
Giscard d'Estaing dire qu'il avait pu
conduire cette opération grâce à la
confiance qu'il avait avec son chef
d'état-major particulier et le chef
d'état-major des armées et se retrouver
plus tard chef de l'état-major
particulier et avoir cette confiance
avec un président de la République pour
des opérations comment Libye avec le
président Sarkozy au Mali avec le
président Hollande et bien c'est
extraordinaire je commencerai demain
merci infiniment je vous en prie
ce matin merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
on passe tout de suite au club des
territoires